okay hello everyone so I am going to do
another round of Q&A for kids in others
and a topic again today same as last
week is science fiction what could be
real so we have a few questions that
were left over from last week and maybe
I could start with these so the first
one listed here was how long before we
colonize Mars interesting question you
know I think what has driven
colonization in the past on the earth is
well it's partly just people seeking out
new places to live and so on but it's
also partly the idea that there would be
some valuable goods that could be got
from the mysterious place over the ocean
that you could then sell in the place
you came from and I'm not sure how
that's gonna work out with the Moon and
Mars and so on I mean what are we going
to use them for I think um I certainly
know people who think that we should be
a multi-planet civilization and they
talk about things like well why don't we
have a backup on another planet and I
have to say that things like the
pandemic that we're in right now don't
incredibly encourage that idea because
it kind of only takes you know one trip
from the spacecraft to deliver the virus
to the colony on Mars it's not quite as
separated just because you're on a
different planet doesn't make you quite
as separated as you might have thought
um but so the first question is why go
to the effort to do this then the next
question is how hard is it going to be
to do it so I think one of the questions
is like what are we going to do on the
moon on Mars and so on and it's always
an interesting problem when you think
about new technology new possibilities I
remember when I was a kid there were all
these books that talked about in the
future we will have cities under the
oceans
well turns out we don't why not well
because it's not that useful to do that
so far as we can see there isn't an
immediate use case that um that people
have come up with you know why don't we
have you know we could have sort of a
lot of people in Antarctica we don't
have very many we have a few doing
things like doing astrophysics
experiments that are much more
conveniently done at the South Pole and
elsewhere or particle physics
experiments people studying things that
are best studied in Antarctica but it's
not like we have a bustling metropolis
in Antarctica so you know what could be
done on the moon for example so for
instance on the far side of the Moon
because the moon always has one side
pointed towards the Earth and the other
side away from the earth the far side of
the Moon is for example a very quiet
place when it comes to radio signals so
for example if you want to build a giant
radio telescope giant telescope that
would let you survey the universe in the
radio spectrum if you do it near Earth
well there's all kinds of radio
emissions from the earth radio stations
cell phones all this kind of thing all
kinds of satellites orbiting the Earth
that have radio communications the far
side of the Moon there's none of that
stuff it's always turned away from the
earth and until somebody decides to just
start putting communication satellites
around the moon
there's just no human created radio
emissions there so that's an example of
something one could do now when it comes
to Mars
it's much less clear to me what what we
were so in terms of the moon let me give
you some examples so people said well
let's mine stuff from the moon they said
let's mine what can we mine from the
moon there are asteroids for example
that are rich in certain metals that are
not so common on earth the moon it's
pretty similar to the earth it's
probably because it was formed sort of
more or less that most of it was formed
nor less at the same time as the earth
there were a few ideas like her friend
who first of all thinking about mining
helium-3 on the moon I couldn't quite
figure out why
then he had the idea let's mine moon
rock and you know we have diamonds on
the earth which are which people turn
into gemstones and they're very valuable
and and so on it's like gosh if you know
if you could give somebody a piece of
moon rock wouldn't that be a more
valuable thing than giving them a
diamond I encouraged him to figure out
because diamonds in addition to being
rare somewhat rare um the big ones are
rare they also have the feature that
they refract light in a really cool way
so you know you have a diamond light
goes into the diamond and it bounces
around inside the diamond and then
eventually comes out and it's that
bouncing around inside that makes
diamonds sparkle well there's no reason
to think that moon rock would do that
same kind of thing and actually a big
issue with diamonds is to know exactly
how to cut them exactly what shape to
make so that you maximize all of those
bounces around inside the diamond
crystal um so it's like can you do that
for a moon rock don't know but that's a
pretty thin reason to go to the moon I
mean there are things like send a
spacecraft to the moon and you know have
sent back a video and that'll be that'll
be valuable so it's like you know go to
it go to other planets for entertainment
but that's again a little bit of a thin
reason so okay so that's the the why go
there and it's not completely clear and
and also on Mars there's another issue
which is you know maybe maybe possibly
there was life similar to terrestrial
life on the earth that existed on Mars
at one time who knows maybe it evolved
separately more likely it was probably
seeded by some common source who knows
there are meteorites that managed to get
from Mars to the earth and probably vice
versa so things could have gotten spread
that way but in any case if we go
colonize Mars then it's like you know we
will certainly like for example one
person I know had this idea let's let's
turn Mars into something more like an
earth atmosphere by taking the water
that is in ice form at its poles and
let's put it in the atmosphere and you
can do that by by blowing up a bunch of
hydrogen bombs on the
Poles of Mars maybe you can do that it's
not clear you can um but you know it's
like like well if you do that then if
there ever was little micro fossils of
life on Mars you just completely
destroyed them so it's only case that's
that's the issue of of you know what's
the not not to say that it isn't a
really cool thing to go to Mars and so
on but but the idea that there's an
immediate you know there's an
immediately useful thing to do is not so
clear to me now there's a question of
how do you how do you get there
well one of the main problems is it
takes depends on exactly where Mars and
the earth are and their orbits and so on
but it's gonna take a while maybe six
months to get there and one of the
things that will happen is that when
you're when you're still near the earth
you're sort of protected by the outer
the magnetosphere around the Earth and
things like this from some of the
radiation that comes from the Sun um if
you're in in space deep space you have
things like solar flare it's when the
Sun produces sort of a big flare on its
surface that splits kind of radiation
out into space and it's it's not clear
how you shield from that that's one one
I mean you can but it's not that's that
that's a challenge and then there are
also challenges like how do you really
you know how do you succeed in you know
in a spacecraft in keeping sort of the
environment stable and having them and
so on when you get to Mars you know you
don't it's not so easy to start just you
know growing crops on Mars or something
like this it's not so easy to get a
self-sustaining ecosystem on Mars and
experiments that been done on the earth
to try and make self-sustaining
ecosystems have not been terribly
successful so that that's another
challenge so I think they're they're a
bunch of challenges and you know it's
it's kind of a sad thing because when I
was a kid like let's say 50 years ago I
was really interested in space that was
the time when the moon landings were
happening and so on and everybody
including me just so
assumed that be spacecraft going to Mars
and there'd be Mars colonization in fact
I even produced a little sort of notes
which I still have about you know what
would happen in the 1980s what would
happen in the 1990s and and it was like
for me back in the 1960s it was like of
course we'll colonize Mars by the 1990s
or the early 2000s and sort of
disappointing that that hasn't happened
but it is it is also technically
challenging and one has to sort of have
a a sort of there's a question of why do
that so to speak um let's see well there
are all kinds of questions here um
another question here is why isn't a
tricorder available yet so a tricorder
is this thing in Star Trek
tricorders do all kinds of things but
mostly they sense stuff about things
remotely so you point a tricorder at a
rock that it tells you what kind of rock
it is you point a tricorder at a person
it tells you what's wrong with them
those kinds of things so it's like like
being able to just look at something and
tell things about it actually we're
getting closer to being able to do
things like that so in what happens when
you look at something with your eyes or
whatever you can see some things about
it you can see what color it is you can
see what texture it has what shape it
has all those kinds of things but if
somebody shows you a rock maybe if
you're a good geologist you can say well
I recognize that kind of rock it's a
such-and-such a kind of sandstone
whatever it is but if somebody says well
how much aluminum is in that sandstone
you're like I don't really know you know
it's typically this or that but you
can't really tell and so the question is
can you make a device that will
immediately tell you're looking at a
piece of sandstone how much aluminum is
in the sandstone well it turns out there
are ways to do that so the we
see with our eyes visible light but
there's also infrared ultraviolet light
there's a whole range of different
frequencies of electromagnetic radiation
and there are things that we can tell
from looking at things outside of the
normal visual range that will give us
more information about them in addition
if we shine a laser for example on the
thing and we look at what what kinds of
light come back from the laser hitting
the thing we can tell a lot about what
the thing is and the reason that happens
is when laser light any kind of light
the laser light is really good because
it's very organized light it's light of
a very specific frequency that's
coherent and when when laser light hits
something it all the little molecules in
the thing they absorb the laser light
and the molecules when they remit the
light when they if they if they if they
when normally when when you when you're
looking at your hand or something what's
happening is light from whatever your
lamp or something is hitting your hand
and then that light is being remit Adhan
your hand and that's the light that
comes to your eye and that's what you
see so the way that Rhian works can
depend a lot on the precise molecules
that are there and when you use a for
example laser light and you look at
exactly what gets rio mitad do you get
light of exactly the same frequency as
it slightly shifted in frequency and so
on when you look at that in detail you
can tell a huge amount about what the
molecules in the material actually are
um think it's called romance by trois
Kirby is one of the techniques that's
used to do that and so you could imagine
something like a tricorder that uses
kind of hyper spectral imaging
hyperspectral imaging means you're going
beyond the usual spectrum of light that
we see to see other other kinds of light
and in addition your your you're sensing
much more than just red green blue
you're sensing more than just the colors
that we perceive
you're sensing precisely the frequency
of light that's coming back so if you do
those things it is possible to to sense
more stuff about a thing than what you
can just see with your eyes and actually
there are some devices that come out in
the last few years that allow you to do
that so for example there's one device I
I have one of that's kind of cool that
you pointed it like a piece of chocolate
and it will tell you the fat fat amount
amount of fat in the chocolate and it
does that by using by using this some
this kind of detailed and spectroscopy
idea so so tricorders for telling what
the sort of the the detailed what a
thing is made of that's something that
absolutely is coming hyperspectral
imaging is actually already used with
with food to tell whether the food is
bad or not that's something that you may
not be able to see visually but you can
see by looking at these these detailed
there are features of the of the of the
light that is Israel is sent back from
from from from the food um it's also the
case that one really cool thing that one
could potentially do with these kinds of
techniques is look so normally when so
if you have like a Fitness watch or
something that's measuring your heart
rate the way it does that is using a
thing called the PPG sensor you'll see
it typically flashes green light if you
take your your Fitness watch off it'll
have flashes of green light those
flashes of green light are basically
they're going through your skin and they
are the it's that the the the watch is
is trying to see exactly what light is
sent back from the blood that's um
that's underneath your skin and
depending on whether that blood has some
depending on whether there's more oxygen
or less oxygen in the blood the exact
color that's that sent back will change
and so when your heart beats every time
your your heart beats you know you're
pumping
oxygenated blood through through through
Oh ultimately through capillaries and
things but your pumping through
oxygenated blood and that has a slightly
different color than an oxygenated blood
and that PPG sensor is detecting that so
that's a one sort of simple example of
how you can use something like light and
the details of how the light is is is
coming back from from things to measure
some properties so right now
PPG sensors just measure the amount of
oxygen in the blood and they lets you
figure out how fast your heart is
beating and so on but um one can imagine
people have hoped that it will be
possible to make similar kinds of
sensors that will detect other things in
your blood so for example one that's
that's very very much been looked at
although still not successfully done is
detecting the amount of glucose and
blood that's relevant particularly for
people who are diabetic figuring out
what term right right now the primary
way to figure out how much glucose that
is in your blood is to put a small
catheter in and and measure sort of the
electrochemistry of of the glucose
inside you so to speak but if you could
do that just with with with light you
would be able to do it non invasively
without sticking anything inside you and
potentially there are probably hundreds
maybe thousands of different kinds of
things that circulate around in our
blood and if you could have something
that would be sort of a tricorder like
thing that would be able to sense just
by shining the right kind of light and
seeing what gets reflected back would be
able to sense all those things in your
blood you would have something it's a
pretty decent approximation to the kind
of Star Trek medical tricorder and
similarly when it when it's like what
kind of rock is this you can expect that
to work as well I think this is
something that will actually be coming I
mean sort of waiting for it for a decade
or so now using hyperspectral imaging as
a way to tell material that what what a
material actually is but it's something
I think is going to come
so let's see other questions here one
will be able when will be able to 3d
print medicines that's an interesting
question so so most medicines operate at
a molecular scale most medicines very
common thing that they're doing is
there'll be some molecule that exists in
you and there'll be a molecule that that
normally does a particular thing but if
only you could Jam so let's say it does
something and you you want to stop it
doing that thing so it'll do the thing
by by basically let's say having other
molecules come in and bind to a
particular place on that molecule
they'll get stuck in a little little
[Music]
sort of a hole in that molecule it's a
certain shape that's the right shape to
fit the molecule but they're trying to
fit in there
so one thing that some medicines do is
they they they block those places where
other molecules can bind that's one
example of what medicines can do and so
then what you want to do is you want to
make a molecule of the right shape to
stick it in that hole so that you can
have that medicine going and stick in
the hole rather than having the molecule
you don't want to go there that's what
one example another example would be
various kinds of medicines that attach
to things on the surface of a cell again
at a molecular scale they're looking at
this shape of molecule is kind of
fitting like a like a lock-and-key into
this other shape that's on the on the
surface of the cell so when you think
about like 3d printing medicines what
you'd be trying to do there is to
basically construct molecules that have
exactly the right shape and also
electrical charge distribution but
basically the right shape to fit into
these places that you want to use
medically and so one of the questions
what sort of a it's not discussed maybe
smile and maybe it is discussed in
science fiction is the question of can
you make a machine that will essentially
3d print at a molecular scale you know
three
printers we have today mostly work by
having little tiny granules of plastic
for example that they would fuse on to
on to something that they're printing
something like that or sometimes they
have the sort of the the a thing where
they use light and they make um they
make it so that the thing will be
hardened if the light fell there and not
hardened if it isn't those kinds of
things but but um the question is could
you could you actually make a 3d printer
that places individual atoms so we have
actually atomic force microscopes that's
a microscope for looking at at things at
an atomic scale but you can also use
that same technology to place individual
atoms but you can't do very many of them
it's not a another thing where you could
like build a big thing that way but um
so one of the questions which is kind of
a I think an important problem is can
you make a nanotechnology manufacturing
machine that basically just you give it
a you give it a specification a sort of
a a plan for make this molecule and it
will go off and somehow actually create
that molecule that's something in the
next I don't know decade to three it's
something that I think might become
possible um people kind of worked on
that a lot about twenty years ago
and sort of gave up it's like this is
too hard I'm never a great believer in
though this is too hard theory um we
don't know how to do it yet but we could
imagine something which is made from
little molecules maybe you know this
molecule is controlled in this way and
has a little head that tries to you know
put down carbon atoms in just the right
place I don't know some some young
person because it may take a while
should should start to try and figure
out how to do this because you can do
this you'll be able to make essentially
a universal constructor of molecules of
different shapes I mean when we do
chemistry for example what we're doing
is you know we might have some some way
of doing chemical synthesis that you
might learn in school or something where
it says heat this chemical combine it
with this do that it's a very indirect
way of constructing molecules we don't
have a direct way of just saying this is
the shape of molecule I want just
assemble the atoms in the right way
that's something that Tim and if we
could do that we could we could think
about doing the equivalent of 3d
printing medicines
we have another question here um how
would teleportation work if we could
make it happen that's a kind of a
complicated thing because it's like
actually relates to what I was just
talking about about constructing things
at the level of atoms cuz let's say that
what you could do is say I've got a
thing you know and I will scan that
thing at the atomic level I would say
where's every atom in that thing you
know I've got my I've got my pen and I
say I scan my pen you know every atom in
my pen and then I simply send a signal
to a printer that will then reassemble
my pen Adam for Adam you know does that
count as teleportation or is that not
fair because you had the the original
pen and maybe you still have the
original pen because the scanner didn't
destroy it but maybe the scanner had to
destroy the pen had to take it apart and
then reassemble it at the other end you
know does that count as teleportation or
not um does do you have to sort of move
things faster than speed of light that's
a different issue but anyway so I think
there are sort of questions about what
that means and and also if for example
for an AI for an artificial intelligence
if the artificial intelligence is you
know proudly figuring things out and
it's sitting inside my computer and then
somehow it's some and then I'm going to
can it be teleported to another computer
well the answer is yes it's rather easy
you just take that term the program the
the thing the the what the AI is as a
program you just copy it to the other
computer and it's no big deal it's it's
just done teleportation and as far as
that AI is concerned let's say the AI is
connected to a webcam and it's it's
watching me from my computer and then
well it's the the bits of its program
just get transferred to another computer
and they start up again there's another
webcam on that computer and it's looking
at a different place and it's like that
AI just teleported itself or got
teleported so so it's kind of a thing I
think that's the that's the more
immediate version of teleportation that
is likely to happen
the thing about taking a material object
and you know having something sort of
faster than a rocket so to speak to get
from here to there that's a more
challenging thing that I think is is
possibly not not something that we can
expect to do in physics okay next
question was why don't we have flying
cars yet you know I've seen well I've
I've interacted with a few companies
that say they're building flying cars um
I think an interesting question it's an
interesting question why you know if you
look back in the 1950s and you look at
you know popular science Popular
Mechanics magazine they kept on having
on the cover you know flying cars these
are the cars of the future soon all our
cars were flying cars didn't happen why
not well the thing that got closest to
flying cars was helicopters and
helicopters were sort of you know they
they for many practical purposes that
kind of like flying cars and there was a
period of time when particularly I think
in the 1960s 1970s when it looked like
helicopters are just gonna make it
they've got everyone's gonna have a
personal helicopter why didn't that
happen I think one of the reasons it
didn't happen is helicopters are very
complicated and they are they're hard to
maintain they have lots of things that
sort of have have to be very carefully
maintained because you don't want your
helicopter to just fall out of the sky
one day I don't know that's really the
reason but my impression is that it's
just much simpler to make a car than to
make a helicopter it's also the case
that um one of the issues is controlling
a car is much easier than controlling a
helicopter I mean the you know a car
you're driving it along you're pressing
the gas you're pressing the brake you
know if you if you stop doing those
things nothing terrible will happen for
a few seconds it's um a helicopter well
you know okay so what one of the things
to understand when airplanes were first
being built when the Wright brothers
were first building airplanes back and
what nineteen
I was 18 I was about nineteen hundred a
little bit after nineteen hundred um the
UM the the the challenge was so it's
pretty easy to make a kite the problem
is how do you make a plane that can
readily be controlled and so on and so
the the big issue and the big innovation
of the Wright brothers was figuring out
not how to get the thing to get lift to
go up but how to control the thing so
that you could make it fly in a definite
controlled way and not become unstable
and not just sort of keel over and fall
into the ground and that involved
figuring out how to put little control
surfaces on the wings that you could
move and things like this so that was
kind of the the big innovation was how
do you control it the helicopters the
control problem is significantly more
complicated and I guess at the time when
helicopters sort of looked like they
might become popular it was some solving
that control problem the computers and
things were not really up to being able
to solve that control problem well and
you kind of needed a person particular
when you're landing a helicopter I once
tried doing that it's really hard
because there are all these different
physical effects going on and you kind
of have to you know you have to wiggle
things around in just the right way or
you don't successfully land the
helicopter now a thing that's happened
more recently is quad copters and other
kind of multi rotor typically elect well
always electrical um flying devices and
I think the reason that those have been
able to happen you know small drones
quadrocopters and so on are very common
the reason that was able to happen is
because of the efficiency of electric
motors and the efficiency of batteries
because if you're if you're a battery is
so heavy that with the efficiency of
electric motor you have to run the
rotors and things you just can't lift
the thing off the ground that doesn't
work very well and I think what's
happened now is that we're just getting
to the point where electrical batteries
can store power efficiently enough and
the rotors can the motors can operate
efficiently enough that it's almost
becoming possible to have kind of
human-sized drones and so on and that
can you know operate and take off
vertically and so on so it could very
well be then in the next few years
there'll be something more like flying
cars it's a little unclear you know
there are lot of details like okay you
have a flying car and you're flying cars
motors stop working okay there's one
I've seen which has like 18 motors and
it's like they're all independent they
won't all stop working well that's the
theory at least or you know there are
other schemes like if the motors stopped
working the you know a parachute pops
out I mean it's like elevators in
buildings you know there was a time when
I guess maybe a hundred years ago or
more um when elevators were a very
unsafe thing but then then it got
invented the scheme got invented where
an elevator if an elevator drops in a
building just as a purely mechanical
thing there'll be sort of brakes that
shoot out from the side of the elevator
and it will stop and that's just a pure
sort of mechanical engineering trick
that made elevators much safer than they
had been and one can imagine similar
things happening for for flying cars
um I don't think you know there are so
so I guess that's I guess my answer
would be it's probably to do with the
control systems nowadays to do with the
way to get power and whether you can get
enough where you can store enough power
for example electrically to run electric
motors that are powerful enough to lift
something that is kind of human size but
my impression is as I said I've seen
demos from several companies of things
that are kind of flying car type form
factors typically which will take one or
two people um and so you know it might
be a coming thing you know I have to say
that the whole issue about how fast
transportation would work and all those
sorts of things keeps on changing
because you know like there was a time
when supersonic planes will really like
that's gonna be the thing that's really
important but the truth is or you know
it's it's really important to have cars
go much faster and so on but then you
know then things happen like cell phones
get invented and people are not sort of
they're not in a situation where oh you
can't do anything when you're in the car
kind of thing
and or laptops got invented and it's
like you're sitting on a plane and you
can't do anything well actually you
can't you just get out your work and
you're connected to the Internet and for
somebody like me it's kind of not that
different from being at my desk so so
some of these things that seem like you
know you really need this but then it
turns out well you don't quite need it
as much as you thought because something
else changed in the technology
okay let's see um all kinds of questions
here can I explain the difference
physical difference between a one volt
on a two volt battery now it's kind of
interesting um well let's see I mean the
batteries make use of electrochemistry
they make use of the fact that there are
chemical processes that produce
electricity and essentially what you're
doing when you make it's kind of how
much of those processes are you putting
are you putting into the battery each
one of those processes will kind of push
the electrons that make electricity a
certain amount and if you put a bunch of
them in series you'll have more of those
you'll you'll kind of push the electrons
more so actually if you take apart some
kinds of batteries it's kind of a
shocking thing you'll find that I don't
know exactly let me make one up but like
a 20 volt battery might actually consist
of five separate pieces that are all 5
volt batteries and they're all kind of
lined up end to end and together they
make a 20 volt battery so that's kind of
the at some level that's the that's the
idea of what's going on it's it's sort
of as simple as that there's a certain
amount of kind of push of electrons that
happens from each of these kind of
layers of chemicals and you put more and
more of those layers together you'll
you'll push the electrons more with more
voltage now now how many electrons you
push that's a different issue
and so batteries are rated by by the
amount of power that they can produce as
well as the voltage so that the the the
amount of that there's the question of
how hard you push the electrons and
there's a question of how many electrons
do push the how hard you pushes the
voltage the how many electrons you
pushes the current voltage is measured
in volts current is measured in amps or
milliamps or whatever and batteries will
have a particular battery will produce a
certain number certain amounts of
pushing of the electrons a certain
amount of number of electrons pushed in
that that's sort of a rating of
different kinds of batteries
let's see have a question here from
Minaj can we manipulate the weather and
formation of clouds
um and something about quantum mechanics
that we're not sure that's relevant so
so one of the questions is can we
control the weather and you know I
always find it interesting back in the
earliest days of science like 4000 years
ago when the Babylonians were just
starting to sort of talk about things
scientifically they would have their
astrologers who would like predict
things about what was going to happen in
the world and there were three kinds of
things that they would often try to
predict they would try to predict you
know when will the planet rise in the
sky will it rain tomorrow and who will
win this or that battle well turns out
the when will the planet rise we really
nailed that one we can really do that
very well now science has let us very
well work out
the motion of planets will it rain
tomorrow science is still kind of a
little bit on the edge of whether it can
do that well and who will win or lose a
battle that's a whole different story
but in terms of controlling the weather
okay
so there have been experiments done for
about 50 60 years trying to do what's
called cloud seeding okay so what is a
cloud a cloud is a big pile of steam
basically a big pile of water vapor and
the way it works says because as you go
up in the air the basically as you go
further away from the earth the air gets
thinner and thinner and depending on how
thin the air is the water vapor steam
may float on the air or not float on the
air it different kinds of things can
happen and so what what happens in
clouds and that there's I'm kind of and
kind of cheating on some of the physics
here but basically what's happening is
as the pressure of the air and the
temperature of the air changes as you go
up the a cloud you'll either get steam
or you won't get steam you'll either get
the water vapor turning into you'll get
a whole bunch of water vapor collect
or you won't and when water vapor
collects it makes a cloud so then the
question isn't and that the inside a
cloud it's like you you just got steam
more or less when you're gonna get rain
what has to happen is that steam has to
condense into little drops of water and
then they get and eventually those drops
of water get heavy enough that they'll
fall out of the cloud so another thing
that's happening is they're usually
updrafts of air underneath the cloud
that are kind of blowing things like
water drops rained potential rain drops
up okay so there's a big thing that
happens in clouds so how does rain get
formed in clouds so what has to happen
is first of all these tiny these these
the steam has to start condensing and
you get larger and larger drops of
larger and larger little tiny pieces of
of water condensing out of the steam and
I think it's 18 microns 18 micrometers
18 millionths of a meter is I think a
critical length at which that's the when
when a cloud goes into an area of
different temperature or different
pressure you can get little little
droplets of water up to about that size
forming by essentially the just the
steam condensing into water in these
little drops to get bigger than that you
need a different process and you
typically need water drops to run into
each other and you get bunch of water
drops running into each other and after
enough water drops to run into each
other they fall out of the cloud and
that's basically how rain gets made and
the so one question is can you make
those water drops form more quickly and
than they would normally in a cloud so
one of the tricky things is okay so
let's say you've got a whole bunch of
water vapor and somewhere and you you
call the water vapor down and it's going
to turn into water liquid water where is
that changing into liquid water going to
start so turns out
um you can actually it's the way the
physics of it works out you kind of have
to have a seed of where the thing is
going to start if you just take the
water vapor and you cool it down all the
atoms are running around in the water
vapor and none of them kind of start
that there's no place where it starts
kind of turning into a drop of liquid
water there's no place where it's called
nucleates into um into a drop of water
doesn't know where to do it so you can
often you know you think that you know
water steam condenses into water at a
hundred degrees centigrade but actually
if you do it carefully enough you can
supercool steam so it's much colder than
100 degrees centigrade and it's still
steam and it doesn't start forming
little drops of water but anytime
there's any kind of anytime there might
be a I don't know a piece of dust or
something in this water vapor that will
serve as a nucleation site that will
serve as a little seed and that that
will start accumulating water and you'll
get this this drop of water forming so
one of the things that it isn't actually
know in that well um how nucleation
starts in water vapor and things like
clouds but what is believed to be the
case is that if you could drop little
dust like things into the cloud you
might be able to start this process of
forming drops of water more efficiently
than would happen normally in the cloud
and then you would be able to make rain
so the thing that is most commonly done
sodium iodide is a common substance that
people will take plane and they'll split
sodium iodide out of the plane into a
cloud and they'll they'll see whether
that causes cloud seeding it's called to
happen causes the the water the vapor in
the cloud to form natural drops and and
fall down as rain
and so people there are different places
I don't know it was I think China
Olympics was one place where I think
this was attempted but it's like we
don't want it to rain for the Olympics
so let's try and get the the clouds to
dump their water somewhere else it's
been very controversial weather cloud
seeding really were
but that's our best effort to try and
control the weather at that level is is
cloud seeding that's the that's the best
known way to do that
um and it's still still a bit unknown
well that can work I mean there are
other sorts of things that are more
electrical that electromagnetic
approaches to doing it which so far
don't really work um but that's that's
kind of the state of that okay um
okay so as a comment from Jay here
there's only merit to discussion about
how about such questions given that the
actualization of our science-fiction
dreams is never literal human flight
planes telepathy teleportation etc you
know it's a question of how good your
science fiction is so to speak you know
there are things that I think it's fair
to say we're sort of predicted in
science fiction communication satellites
is one that's often quoted I haven't
really gone back and looked at Arthur C
Clarke's writings about that but um and
then there's the weird phenomenon that
people know the science fiction so well
that they use the ideas of science
fiction to inform the way that they
actually make technological devices so a
famous example of that was the early
flip phones early cell phones that
flipped themselves open just like a
communicator in in Star Trek actually I
never I never could get my flip phone I
couldn't actually like you know throw it
and the way that a Star Trek
communicator can be open but but it was
close enough you opened it yourself and
that was a case of where sort of fact
was following fiction because people
kind of knew that fiction it was a kind
of a familiar approach to things I would
say that um you know one has a certain
amount of fun kind of imitating things
which are no one means knowing ideas
that come from science fiction like the
howl computer of 2001 has been endlessly
sort of imitated and rift on because
it's sort of a familiar picture of what
technology might be like this question
of can one accurately predict what will
happen do things work the way one
expects them to work well it's a
question how well one predicts them I
mean I think in in my life some of the
things that I've you know I've I've been
very much into trying to figure out
what's going to happen um and sometimes
you can see certain kinds of things that
are sort of inexorably going to happen
you can't necessarily tell how long it
will take and some details may be
different but there are things which are
kind of inexorably going to happen and
there are things that are big surprises
um and I think oh I don't know one that
Tim my wife is fond of reminding me of I
this was back in the one was it it must
have been the early 1990s we're building
a house and there was a question of you
know we're going to have some place
where I want to put a television and as
a question of because of something about
the construction it was the most
convenient thing was just to have this
very very not very deep like a few inch
deep kind of area I never watched
television so I don't really care where
the television goes but anyway this was
a the you know put a television
somewhere and you know what I said and
it's like is it going to be enough to
have you know a four inch deep kind of
recessed thing to put a television there
and you know at the time televisions
were made with cathode ray tubes and
they were these big things that were you
know if they were a large television it
would be a deep thing several feet deep
and so on and I was like no definitely
there will be flat-screen televisions
okay and so you know built this house
with this setup and well turns out they
weren't like stream television at the
time when the house was built actually
flat-screen televisions came in about 10
or 15 years later why did I what was the
mistake the mistake was very subtle
because I knew perfectly well that the
technology existed LCD liquid crystal
display technology existed in fact had
even seen in technology labs I'd even
seen demo versions of LCD displays but
they did not become commercially common
for a decade or more after that time
what went wrong with that prediction
what went wrong was something I
absolutely didn't expect see the fact is
when you make an LCD display it has lots
of little pixels in it that's that's how
the display is made and normally when
you do when you make you manufacture
something like that you might have 10
million pixels and it might be that 20
of those pixels don't work correctly now
for some purposes is not going to matter
the 20 of those pixels don't work but if
you're seeing a display and use an 20
pick
shows on that display never changed
they're always black well gosh you'd
notice that immediately and so what went
wrong was that while it was possible to
make one of these displays the there was
some probability some rate at which the
pixels will be bad and the chance that
you would get no bad pixels and a 10
million pixel display was very low so
you could make these displays but if you
wanted to make sure that they were all
perfect you'd have to make millions of
displays to pick off the one that was
good enough to actually sell and it took
a long time to get to the point where it
was possible to manufacture them so that
there will be few enough errors that
most of the most of the flat-screen
televisions you made would actually work
so it is a very interesting problem I
mean it's a it's a great exercise to try
to figure out given a given a thing
they're given something which is
technically possible or scientifically
possible how will it be used so for
example one right now is space and the
availability of low-cost satellites in
Earth orbit how will they be used what
will we be able to do like for example
things that are coming our real-time
daily imagery of the earth so being able
to get I'm actually a little bit
surprised a couple of companies that
were doing that and I actually haven't
heard from them for a while so don't
quite know what's happened with them but
we're going to be making available
imagery of every place on the earth to
like one meter resolution every once a
day and actually kind of so that you can
make comparisons between what the earth
looks like on one day what some
particular place looks like on one day
on the next day there'd be a particular
local time like who knows what is you
know 10:30 a.m. or something where the
satellites come over and they're gonna
take a picture because that way you're
comparing the shadows will be more or
less the same between two successive
days if it's always at the same local
time each day and obviously sometimes
you know if it's cloudy that day you
won't be able to see to the surface at
least not with visible light but you
know otherwise it's like okay the
satellites coming over let's go let's go
wave a flag at the satellite because we
know it's going to come over at exactly
10:30 a.m. or something but um in any
case the you know that's a thing so
real-time imagery
of the or not real-time but at least
daily imagery of the Earth's surface
later on maybe real-time imagery of the
Earth's surface is one thing that's
coming we don't really know what they'll
be used for I mean it's it's already
useful for example for understanding
crops for example that's a place where
people use that there there are kind of
in the world of trying to do financial
kinds of things people are trying to
predict how well is the store doing
let's see how many people are in its
parking lot today
you know let's count the number of cars
on the parking lot right now that'll be
in most places very very small but um
let's count the number of cars in the
parking lot maybe add some as a way to
figure out how well the store is doing
and let's do that by by having a
satellite image of that parking lot
so there are use cases like that but you
know there are other things that people
wonder about like for example a big
possibility is cell phone being able to
provide cell phone service from orbit
that's not quite as easy as it sounds
because when you have a little cell
phone it's it's easy enough to have a
satellite that's powerful enough that
has a radio antenna powerful enough to
reach your cell phone it's much harder
for your cell phone with its little
battery and with you holding it up to
your head and so on to emit radio waves
that are powerful enough to be detected
by the satellite so it's useful if
you're making kind of base stations or
places where you're communicating lots
of cellphones it's a little less useful
if you want an individual cell phone to
communicate with the satellite but you
know it's an interesting question what
what will be you know if it's really
cheap to put things in orbit what will
we do with them and you know people sort
of say well we'll have ads in orbit and
so on you know and we'll have people
said for a while though it'll be a good
place to grow crystals because it's
easier to grow crystals in the
microgravity in the an essentially
weightless state that things are when
they're orbiting in orbit and things but
but it's not clear what the it's a good
exercise to try and figure out and I
like doing these things because you know
I kind of try to try to figure out
what's going to happen and then I sort
of maybe even write it down or at least
remember it and then five years goes by
10 years goes by and it's like okay I
knew that was going to happen or what
so I didn't see that coming you know let
me use that that mistake to inform later
things that I try to predict
okay
um
okay I'm gonna take come let's see
some questions here all right hard to
choose between them why there's a
question here from Jamie asking what are
my thoughts on starshot projects that
will attempt sheathing satellites to
Alpha Centauri with lasers so you know
the traditional view of how do you send
a spacecraft somewhere is you you have
your spacecraft you have a rocket it has
rocket fuel you and you you know burn
the rocket fuel and it produces it it
sends gas at high speed out of the back
of the rocket and that's what pushes the
rocket forward but typically that
happens only for a short time and then
you've burnt up all the fuel and then
the rocket just coasts after that well
if you want to get to Alpha Centauri
which is four light-years away
um it's see how many million miles away
I'd have to have to do some some math or
a score from alpha that um but it's
millions of miles away
um and to to reach it going if if you
just the fastest Rockets that we've made
go at about a hundred thousand miles an
hour and reaching Alpha Centauri at that
speed would take a ridiculously long
time um
the and the question is can you make a
rocket that will just keep accelerating
keep going faster and faster and faster
and faster until it gets up to something
even close to the speed of light and get
it to make it all the way to to the
Alpha Centauri
so one scheme for doing that is instead
of having the rocket have fuel on the
rocket you have something where you're
essentially pushing the rocket from
Earth and just having it keeping on
pushing it and so I think I mentioned in
one of these other life streams the idea
of radiation pressure and solar sailing
when light hits a mirror it pushes the
mirror just a little tiny bit because
the photon of light just like you'd hit
something with like a billiard ball and
billiard ball bounce off when the
billiard ball bounces mouth it pushes
the thing that it bounces from well
similarly when a photon of light hits a
mirror when it bounces off it's pushing
the mirror just a little bit and so the
idea is to have a laser on the earth a
high-power laser that will just keep
pushing this sort of solar sail that
would be a big big piece of very light
material that um is in space and
reflects the light back and keep pushing
that and keep pushing it and keep
pushing it and use that to make the
thing go really fast now eventually it
got would get so far away that it that
the laser from the earth spreads out too
much there's not enough you don't you
don't get enough intensity of laser
light on the sail and it can't really
push it any further
but ton that's kind of the idea and
actually I I have I have one of these
little things they got them from from
somebody the little tiny prototypes of
those some starships so to speak they're
about that big and they have little
antennae that hang out there little tiny
pieces of wire that hang out that might
be that might be able to produce a very
very not very intense radio signal maybe
intense enough that we could detect it
with a big really big radio telescope
but so I think it's an interesting idea
I think it's pretty challenging I think
that it's kind of our our our most
obvious short-term hope for getting
something that will be a spacecraft that
can go to Alpha Centauri and kind of the
idea is you you you send off a whole
swarm of these little tiny spacecraft
and you hope that some of them will make
it to Alpha Centauri we'll be able to
and maybe we'll be able to get some data
from there and and that you'll be able
to pick up radio signals from them and
and and learn about what's going on
there now you know another thing that
happens is a telescope telescopes are
limited in
just the properties of light limit how
far away a telescope can resolve things
so for example you might say let's have
a telescope that's you know on the earth
and that's just looking at Alpha
Centauri and let's just make our
telescope really big and really high
magnification and let's just see if
there's anybody hanging out on planets
around Alpha Centauri or something well
the reason that doesn't work is because
there's a limit on how how good a
telescope we can make and that limit is
a result of properties of light
basically in order to make a really
really good telescope you have to be
able to focus light really really well
and because light acts like a wave
that's of a certain size you can't focus
the light down into a size that's kind
of small compared to the size of the
wave that corresponds to the light
that's one problem the other problem is
the Earth's atmosphere kind of fuzzers
things out so let's say you put the
space you put a telescope in orbit like
the Hubble Space Telescope then you're
not dealing with the Earth's atmosphere
maybe you put it on the far side of the
Moon you don't have all the light from
the earth and so on um you know you've
got your telescope there and now you
want to make a telescope that has a
really high resolution that can really
see things so it helps to have a really
big telescope to have a really big
aperture for your telescope as a formula
that tells you how how how well the
telescope will be able to see how much
it can resolve based on basically the
size of the telescope but even then
there are some limits but one of the
things that we're sort of learning
slowly is that by playing some tricks
with quantum mechanics and and and
looking at light as particles photons
and looking at not just one photon but
multiple photons altogether it may be
possible to make sort of much much
better telescopes that kind of seem that
that sort of get around the limitations
that we thought existed in how good a
telescope you can make so it may
actually be possible to quotes directly
see things that are a very high
resolution that are from you know just
the very small amount of light that's
making it to us from let's say a planet
around Alpha Centauri we might be able
to actually pick that up and
reconstruct from those few photons of
light that are arriving we might be able
to reconstruct even images of things
there and that may be a more of a better
way to kind of find out what's going on
there then send a little spacecraft I
don't know we have to see um
you
okay let's see
here from Einstein von Rembrandt could a
technologically advanced civilization
arise on a planet completely covered in
water oh of course I mean the idea that
you know that civilization has to be
exactly the way that our civilization is
it's just because that's the one example
of civilization we know I mean good
whales have constructed a civilization
if left for enough millions of years I
don't see why not
I mean the details of you know it's like
things you can make with flippers rather
than things you can make with hands well
they're different things you can make
who knows maybe the whales are even
making them and we just don't recognize
them maybe they're making amazing sort
of whale artifacts by arranging you know
by flipping their flippers around to
arrange the pattern of plankton in the
ocean to be a particular way well we
don't even notice because we don't have
detectors and we don't recognize what
they're doing I mean it's kind of like
recognizing archaeological artifacts on
the earth of you know is this a stone
circle or do these stones just happen to
be this way so you know I think that um
it's it's something where yeah I think
you know the the particular way that a
civilization has developed is just a lot
of accidents in history and I just don't
think that there's anything that would
prevent that I mean I think that's of
interest because there are certainly
outer planets some I'm trying to
remember which is it Enceladus moon of
Saturn and not remembering my astronomy
very well and I guess recently Pluto
exclaimed probably has a liquid water or
liquid ocean inside it I mean it's kind
of bizarre that Pluto a very very far
away from the Sun can still maintain
liquid water potentially liquid water
inside it how does that happen
what happens because when Pluto was
originally formed it was hot and you
might say well gosh that was that was
you know four billion years ago
how come it's still hot inside what
turns out that heat doesn't through rock
he doesn't transport very efficiently
and you could actually have something
which is like like you have a you know
you might use styrofoam or something to
try and keep heat in
you have a thermos flask or something
like this to try and sort of keep heat
into something um and you might turn and
that works up to a point but by the time
you have a big layer of rock it turns
out you can keep stuff hot for a really
long time like billions of years
actually two things going on so the heat
of the earth so if you drill down in the
earth as you probably know the earth has
a liquid core so there's rock on the
surface of the earth that's the crust of
the earth if you drill down like 50
miles or something you'll get to the
liquid core of the earth people haven't
been able to drill anything like that
far they've drilled to the point where
it's getting pretty hot but not to the
point where you're actually at the the
liquid where they where where there's
where it starts to be liquid but um so
the the earth is liquid inside it's hot
inside at the very centre of the earth
is thousands of degrees centigrade um
it's how does it come to be hot inside
well there are two reasons it's thought
one is well it didn't cool down from
when it was formed 4.6 billion years ago
it's still cooling down inside as heat
is gradually transmitted to the surface
and then and then radiated into space
that's thing number one thing number two
there are radioactive elements in the
earth like uranium that slowly decay and
slowly their nuclear I fall apart and
when their nuclei fall apart they
produce heat and some of those elements
because of the way the nuclear physics
works and those elements take billions
of years to decay and so they're still
decaying now the elements that were put
into the earth when it was first formed
is still decaying now and so some part
of the heat of the earth comes from
radioactive decay some part of it is
remnant heat from when the earth was
formed same presumably happens and
things like Pluto and that's why even
though you're far far away from the Sun
you can have liquid water now you know
there are people think about I think
Enceladus there's discussions about
spacecraft missions there where it's
like can you drill through two
kilometres of ice or something on the
surface to get to the ocean underneath
and you know what kind of weird
spacecraft do you need to be able to do
that and if you drill through its kind
of been you know it's been sterile
a billion years or something under there
there's nothing from the outside
probably has managed to get in so like
there could be all kinds of critters in
there and be kind of embarrassing and
upsetting if if we drilled through their
ice and and suddenly we you know we get
to the inside and we we kill them all
off that would be really bad so so it's
it's a but I think this idea it's kind
of an interesting thing to imagine if
you're a critter that lives inside this
this liquid core inside Pluto let's say
and there's nothing outside you know you
don't know what's outside and people
would have all these theories about how
we're inside this liquid core of this
planet or something um and you know
there probably be some crazy scientist
who'd be saying you know well actually
if you if we just were able to drill
through the sky so to speak we'd get to
something different on the other side
and everybody would think that person
was that critter was nuts
so okay questions here I should wrap up
soon but let me um look at a few of
these oh there's a question here um from
Luis kind of tardigrade survive on Mars
so tardigrades are these some are they
called they're also called water what
are they called and there's kind of very
ugly looking creatures they're very
small and they they can basically
hibernate for a really long time and the
and they can survive when it's really
cold when it's really they don't have to
eat anything they're just sort of frozen
for long periods of time and I think the
answer is okay so friend of mine who is
has a project called the arch arc
mission which whose whose goal is to put
human artifacts around the solar system
put a little package of stuff on to an
Israeli spacecraft because was last year
that went to the moon and the idea was
the spacecraft would do a soft landing
on the moon and this these artifacts
from the earth that included all kinds
of micro
versions of all sorts of books and
things would would sit on the moon for
the next however many years and sort of
safely backed up relative to the earth
okay that was the idea unfortunately due
to a malfunction on the spacecraft the
spacecraft crashed into the lunar
surface at 2,000 kilometers an hour so
the this payload we initially thought
the payload would have just been
vaporized but actually what happened was
the spacecraft crashed into the moon in
a very glancing angle and almost
certainly based on photographs from the
Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter almost
certainly the spacecraft hit the Hitmen
lunar surface and actually bounced and
probably slid maybe as much as a
kilometer because there isn't as much
gravity there's only one-sixth of
gravity on the moon and also so long as
you don't hit a boulder you can just
slide on the surface of the moon a
really pretty long way so so most likely
the spacecraft was actually not
completely destroyed and this payload
probably survived is probably on the
moon somewhere okay in a piece of I
would say not very good judgment um one
of the things this friend of mine put in
the payload was a bunch of tardigrades
um and so these some these critters who
were supposed to be in a very sealed
container but a container that sealed
with you if you crash it into the moon
at 2,000 kilometers an hour what you
thought was sealed might not be so
sealed anymore but um so there are some
tardigrades on the moon and I think I
think the expectation is that there that
they survived and that if they were
rehydrated if they were put in water
again and things at a reasonable
temperature that they would just come
back and and and sort of be happy tap
but again I think um okay so
let's see
um
[Music]
and here we should build a pyramid on
the moon that'd be cool
it's a kind of artifact you know the
pyramids are one of the human artifacts
that has lasted the longest and you know
it's a big question what do you put on
the moon okay so so I have another
friend who has a project to search for
artifacts on the moon and so his idea is
take all the lunar reconnaissance
photography and search for things that
might be artifacts like what if some
civilization had visited the moon and
put a pyramid there would we even know
it well we have pretty high-resolution
photography of the surface of the Moon
now but so we might go through them we
look at look at the surface of the Moon
and we say is there anything that looks
like it was made by somebody on purpose
or something on purpose
well if we saw a pyramid the it's like
what would we conclude okay so and yes
in in the movie 2001 I came out in 1968
one of the dramatic things and that
movie was the thing called tma-1
which was a it stood in the movie for a
tycho magnetic anomaly Tycho has a
crater on the moon and the idea was that
that the the storyline was that had been
detected that there was this intense
source of magnetism in the in that
crater and then it was excavated and
then what was there was the slab that
was a black slab with ratio with its
length ratios one to four to nine and
the black slab just sat there except
when the black slab was exposed to the
Sun it sent out an intense radio signal
okay so that was the and the kind of the
the concept of the movie was if you saw
this perfect black slab you would
immediately know that was the thing that
was created on purpose and there was a
philosopher actually from a couple of
centuries ago Immanuel Kant who who said
um you know if we saw hexagons drawn in
the sand we would know that must have
been created on purpose
nothing would naturally have done that
it's too perfect it's too mathematical
so to speak to been created any other
way
well you might say that but it turns out
that there are actually things that
happen because of wind and sort of
swirling patterns of wind that actually
make hexagons in sand so it's kind of
like well we see a hexagon in the sand
can we really conclude somebody drew it
on purpose not really the wind could
have made it and the really embarrassing
thing about hexagons is if you look at
the North Pole of Saturn and you look at
it in in spacecraft photographs it has a
giant hexagon that is the shape of a
storm near the North Pole of Saturn so
we don't think anybody did that on
purpose
anything did that on purpose it's just
the way that the physics of the
atmosphere of Saturn works that it makes
this hexagon and so the it's some the
the the thing that so that this idea of
what do you put on the moon that makes
it look like the it makes it look like
kind of something intelligent did it
it's not very obvious and it's not even
obvious on the earth you know you look
at the earth I asked years ago I asked
some astronauts I knew you know what do
you see on the earth that makes it
obvious that there's a civilization here
said what do you see and you know what
time what features of the earth make
civilization obvious so at the time they
said the most obvious thing isn't the
Great in the Great Salt Lake in Utah
there is a perfect straight line that
separates one part of the lake that is
one color another part of the lake
that's another color and so it's a kind
of a straight line that you see from
orbit and turns out that's a causeway
that was built and that there's algae of
one kind on one side and as I'll give
another kind on the other side so they
tend to be different colors so it's a
sort of dramatic line I said what else
do you see okay so there's another thing
in New Zealand as Mount Egmont I think
it is is I think it has a new name
actually that's an indigenous name which
I now forget but
there's a there's a mount Egmont and I I
was doing this research for his book I
wrote in the 1990s and was sort of
before the web was popular so I had to
like send email to people and ask
questions and things um and there so
anyway there's this there's this volcano
in New Zealand and there's a sort of
perfect circle around this volcano and
so I was wanted to get information about
this so we we contacted the New Zealand
Geological Survey and they said they
said you know if you're writing a
geology textbook please don't say that
the crater of this volcano is a perfect
circle the perfect circle where has
nothing to do with the volcano it has to
do with the fact that there's a boundary
of a national park that was drawn as a
perfect circle and there are sheep that
graze I forget whether it's outside or
inside the National Park and so the
grass is different on the two sides of
the inside the circle as opposed to
outside the circle and that's what makes
the perfect circular baton but that's
another piece of evidence of sort of
human civilization on the earth but it's
actually pretty hard to find these
things and you know the fact that if you
look at other places on the earth there
are actually pretty good circular pretty
pretty close to circular craters and
pretty close to circular other features
on the earth and it's really hard to
tell you know was that an intentionally
drawn National Park or was it just a
natural phenomenon so so this project to
go see whether there are artifacts on
the moon it's an interesting but
challenging project because like you
know it could be that there's was a
great alien artist who drew this amazing
picture on the surface of the Moon that
is a fantastic piece of alien art but we
just wouldn't recognize it because it
doesn't have anything that relates to
kind of our notions of what represents
order um the it's okay I'm noticing
Pingu asking I'm sure Elon Musk will do
worse things to the moon than polluting
it with water bears okay I don't know
whether I should tell the story but but
termite I don't tend to tell too many of
these but I I just as a conversation I
have with you on a few years ago that
term just featured a priceless line I
thought I was mentioning
[Music]
I was mentioning the the the so-called
terraforming of Mars we were talking
about kind of how whether it's realistic
to get the atmosphere of Mars to be to
be um I have to tell you a little bit of
backstory here but but whether it's
whether it's possible to get Mars to
have an atmosphere more like the earth
and I mentioned earlier this idea of
detonating a bunch of hydrogen bombs
near the poles of Mars that have that
have ice in them and causing and
producing you know gently putting water
vapor into the into the Martian
atmosphere that way so anyway I okay so
that's that's first thing second thing I
have to tell you a little bit of
historical story so when people were
doing archeology particularly in the
1800s became very popular to try and
excavate ancient sites and the the thing
that um so there were there was these
things that have been described in for
example Homer had described the city of
Troy you know the Iliad is all about the
the Trojan Wars and you know all the
stuff that was going on around the city
of Troy but nobody had found the city of
Troy it wasn't clear whether that was
just a story that Homer had made up
whether there was actually a city of
Troy so there was a German archaeologist
named Lehmann who went to find the city
of Troy and he eventually did find the
city of Troy but it turns out that like
many ancient cities
Troy was built in many layers so there
was you know try one try to try three
and you know after a hundred years or
something Troy would be I don't know
what would happen to it maybe the the
Greeks would invade a like in the Trojan
War and they would you know and all the
buildings would would would collapse or
something when they build another
version of Troy on top of it so there
were many layers of Troy so one of the
things that Tim that Sriman did was
trying to get through all these layers
of Troy he was like the first layer well
it's not very interesting the one at the
top not very interesting let's just use
dynamite to blow through the top layers
and because we really want to get down
to the layer that Homer talked about far
below
so he used dynamite and blew up the top
few layers of Troy and in fact he
probably blew through the the the the
the first the layer of Troy that might
have been the one that Homer was
describing okay so that's a bit of
backstory but anyway this conversation
fragment that I just thought was was
kind of funny was was Elon was
explaining to me about how you know this
whole idea of detonating hydrogen bombs
and and Mars and we've been talking
about you know life on Mars and so on
and so I my comment was you know well
then you know it was about life on Mars
and so on it's like if you do that you
detonate hydrogen bombs on there and the
poles of Mars
you'll be the Schliemann of Mars because
it's like just like if there was ever
any life on Mars the and the you know
and the poles of Mars you just blew it
up with hydrogen bombs so anyway I just
thought that was so funny
as conversation fragments go kind of out
of context it's kind of a weird thing to
explain but that Tim I thought I think I
think it's not some think that's that's
amusing enough to be to be repeated so
to speak um okay I'm just um maybe one
more and then we should wrap up for
today let's see oh there's two good ones
here um why haven't
historic aminals been resurrected yet
okay I'm going to talk about prehistoric
animals and I'm going to talk about
antimatter for a second okay the
question was why haven't prehistoric
animals been resurrected yet so you know
first question is so we know the DNA the
genetic material of current organisms
and we can actually figure out from
knowing about different organisms you
know birds reptiles mammals etc we can
we can extrapolate back to some extent
what the ancestors of those animals must
have been like what kind of DNA they
might have had and and we know a certain
amount from that be really convenient if
we could actually get the the actual DNA
of for example an actual dinosaur and
well you know the movie Jurassic Park
for example features sort of DNA
extracted from the from from a dinosaur
DNA that's ain't going to be recreated
actually friend of mine was the science
consultant for that movie and one of the
things he regrets about the movie was at
the time of the movie he's a
paleontologist and studies fossils and
things and you know he had a bunch of
theories and he put basically all his
theories into that movie and it turns
out about half the theories were right
and half the theories were wrong but he
says everybody now believes all of the
theories including the ones that
completely wrong which because they're
in that movie and so it's kind of a a.m.
so there are things in that movie that
are just you know turned out they just
don't work they're just not right there
other ones that are right but so it's
kind of funny that that um that that's
you know that's how science fiction
becomes science so to speak or or maybe
even get science a bit off track in that
case I think the main result is to be
able to anyway so that the concept in
that movie was dragonfly you know not
dragonfly mosquito you know sucks blood
of dinosaur which has DNA in it most
tl gets trapped in a piece of amber
lasts for you know 100 million years we
get the mosquito the DNA DNA molecules
are very stable so there's a decent
chance we could extract the DNA from
that and figure out the DNA of the
dinosaur that hasn't hasn't happened yet
we do have somebody's pointing out on
the live stream here we do have mammoth
DNA that's because we actually have
mammoths you know mammoths existed up
until Roman times they were still
mammoths and the you know mammoths there
are mammoths that have been found frozen
in Siberian permafrost and so on so you
know mammoths are out well they're not
out and about but they are you know you
can you can find a a a fully sort of a
fully existent mammoths so to speak and
extract its DNA now you know can we make
a [ __ ] we use that DNA to make a viable
baby mammoth I suspect the answer is yes
I mean I I suspect
I've forgotten what's happened to this I
mean a few years ago people are very
enthusiastic about growing mammoths and
and you know in elephants and so on and
I don't know what's happened to that but
I would fully expect that that will be
something that's possible whether you'll
be able to get a pet Stegosaurus running
around from you know 100 million years
ago that's that's less clear but I kind
of think that that will eventually be
possible it requires possibly you know
you won't have the DNA you'll have to
manufacture the DNA and it's difficult
to manufacture a whole long DNA sequence
like that but it's becoming
progressively easier then you have to
find you know when you create an
organism there's more to the organism
than just its DNA you have to have sort
of something which will at least pretend
to be something like the the egg so to
speak the other things in the dinosaur
egg that aren't just the DNA that codes
for the construction of the dinosaur so
that will be a challenge but I would
fully expect that in time it will be
possible to do that and it'll be it'll
be kind of interesting and you know it's
sort of there's sort of a trade-off
between having reconstructing ancient um
animals and making a designer critter
for yourself I mean it's it's another
thing that's in science fiction famously
in a movie called Blade Runner the
starts with this genetic tinkerers Otis
Peake who's created all these all these
creatures that were capable of doing
things like come the you know instead of
having technology you know electrical
technology that opens your door and
things it's like have a little creature
that sole function is opening the door
for you and so on and and that was
actually I would say that about some 30
years ago person who wasn't one of my
favorites actually but who died recently
but but he was very contrary and kind of
fellow and he he kept on saying
computers aren't the thing all this
electronics that's not the future of
technology the future of technology is
custom biology in other words the future
of technology is not to make a digital
device with electricity and so on the
future of technology is to engineer a
creature that will do what you want so
instead of making I don't know what a
instead of making your your your flying
car make a creature that has these you
know wings that people can just sit on
the back of this creature and it will it
will take off and take them places that
will be a better way to to build
technology than than to use electronics
and so on turned out well turns out so
far that profoundly did not work and
although when we want to connect to so
biomedical things we are interested in
making molecular scale things that sort
of fit into our biology but when it
comes to that your typical technological
thing the electrical digital thing is
much better all right there's some I
think we should we should wrap it up for
here the someone's making saying they
don't want a mammoth pet they want a
clone that can work two shifts they want
to make a clone of themselves you know
one of the things that that I'm curious
about is some you know I record a lot of
stuff that I do so you know when I type
my record every keystroke I record all
the emails I've been doing that for like
30 years and so I've collected
millions of emails you know huge amounts
of stuff that I've produced you know I'm
recording this live stream and so on so
the question is at what point will be
there be enough data about me that you
could basically reconstruct me at what
point will there be something where
you've seen enough millions of I got
this email I responded this way that you
could make essentially an AI that will
respond in the same way that's a that's
a fun question and you know there's a
separate issue which is a biological
clone and maybe another time we'll talk
about cloning humans and and that whole
story it's an interesting ok I'll say
one thing about that as people may know
in the 1990s there was so you know
normally you know we all have certain
DNA and the only way that we get to sort
of make use of that DNA if we're mammals
or something is to have children and the
children make use of half of our DNA but
um the other idea is you just take the
DNA and you make an identical copy of
the organism by just saying I'll just
grow an organism with that particular
DNA so that was something that people
had said for years mammalian cloning is
impossible they just said just can't
work just can't be done and I used to
ask people why is it impossible why you
know explain to me why is it impossible
you know why can't we take the DNA out
of one you know egg cell and put it in
another and restart the thing and have
it all work and so on um it's uh and I
know it give explanations it's like why
isn't it possible well turned out in the
mid-1990s people discovered how to do
that for in fact for a sheep first of
all and it's a weird process and
involves electricity and it involves a
bunch of other things but in the end
that procedure lets one make a clone in
that case of a sheep um and so you know
mammalian cloning is possible you know
is it and in the case of a lot to say
about about cloning humans human organs
things like that maybe I'll talk about
that another time
all right um oh boy there's a comment
from Reese here be interesting to
engineer a seed to grow a house yeah
that's a cool idea I mean people people
have looked at that I mean the the
notion of can you you know you want to
grow a treehouse you know can you can
you make a tree that will grow in the
shape of a house so to speak can you
make something where where you have sort
of a growing house forget the idea that
you're a house you know it's kind of
like the ultimate term I don't know what
so you know a thing where where you make
your house not out of wood that way of
trees that you cut down but of trees
that are actually growing and somehow
you control you know you can actually
control the growth of trees plants have
these things called auxins which are
like our hormones and those grow those
determine the growth of plants so for
example if you want to make a tree
sprout a branch to some extent you can
do that by just sort of injecting this
plant aux-in and that will make it kind
of ground grow a branch in a certain way
so you might ask the question could you
make this tree so that it will grow in
just the right shape to make the house
your dream house so to speak and I don't
think we know you can't do that so it's
kind of a maybe a coming attraction of
the the ultimate eco house there's a
house that is made out of growing trees
all right I think we've we've we veered
off into into some some curious things
but let's let's wrap it up here and I'll
I think I should be able to continue
with this next week if people are
interested so thanks for joining us and
thanks for a lot of a lot of fun
questions you've made me think about a
lot of things that I don't normally
think about so I appreciate that thanks
very much
bye